let's get some practice solving some
exponential equations and we have one
right over here we have 26
to the 9x plus 5 power
equals 1. so pause the video and see if
you can tell me what x is going to be
well the key here is to realize that 26
to the 0th power
to the 0th power is equal to 1.
anything to the 0th power is going to be
equal to one zero to zero power we can
discuss it some other time but anything
other than zero to the zero power is
going to be one
so we just have to say well nine x plus
five needs to be equal to zero
nine
x plus five
needs to be equal to
zero and this is pretty straightforward
to solve subtract five from both sides
and we get nine x is equal to negative
five divide both sides by
nine and we are left with x is equal to
negative five
let's do another one of these and let's
let's make it a little bit more a little
bit more interesting
let's say we have the exponential
equation
2
to the 3 x plus 5 power
is equal to
64
to the x minus seventh
power
once again pause the video and see if
you can tell me what x is going to be or
what x needs to be to satisfy this
exponential equation
all right so
you might at first say oh maybe 3x plus
5 needs to be equal to x minus 7 but
that wouldn't work because these are two
different bases you have 2 to the 3x
plus 5 power then you have 64 to the x
minus 7. so the key here is to express
both of these with the same base
and lucky for us 64 is a power of two
two to the let's see two to the third is
eight so it's going to be two to the
third times two to the third eight times
eight is sixty-four so it's two to the
sixth is equal to
sixty-four and you can verify that take
six twos and multiply them together
you're going to get 64. this is just a
little bit easier for me eight times
eight and this is the same thing as 2 to
the 6th power is 64. and i knew it was
to the 6th power because i just added
the exponents because i had the same
base
all right so i can rewrite 64. let me
rewrite the whole thing so this is 2 to
the
x plus 5 power is equal to instead of
writing a 64 i am going to write 2 to
the sixth power
2 to the sixth power
and then that to the x minus 7th power
x minus 7 power
and to simplify this a little bit we
just have to remind ourselves that if i
raise something
to 1 power and then i raise that to
another power this is the same thing as
raising my base to the product of these
powers a to the b c power
so
this equation i can rewrite as 2 to the
3 x plus 5
is equal to
2
to the and i just multiply 6 times x
minus 7. so it's going to be 6x
6
x
minus
6 times 7 is 42.
i'll just write the whole thing in
yellow so 6 x
minus
42. i just multiplied the 6 times the
entire expression x minus 7. and so now
it's interesting i have 2 to the 3x plus
5 power has to be equal to 2 to the 6x
minus 42 power
so these need to be the same exponent
so 3x plus 5 needs to be equal to 6x
minus 42.
so there we go it sets up a nice little
linear equation for us 3x plus 5 is
equal to 6x
minus 42.
let's see
we could get all of our since well i'll
put my all my x's on the right hand side
since i have more x's on the right
already so let me subtract 3x from both
sides
and let me i want to get rid of this 42
here so let's add 42 to both sides
and we are going to be left with
5 plus 42 is 47
is equal to
47 is equal to
3 x
now we just divide both sides by 3 and
we are left with x is equal to
47 over 3
x is equal to 47
over 3
and we are done